hover haps a German newspaper once
described him as a man with a heart
ambition and a big mouth both kankakee
is a lawyer a staunch liberal in the
European sense and the deputy leader of
Germany's pro-business ftp party hello
hello healthy economy welcome to the DW
interview I'm Alexandra from narmin heck
will be caviezel mr. kubicki the
so-called Panama papers have caused a
major stir they show how the rich and
powerful use tax havens and shell
companies to conceal their wealth many
people in Germany are outraged immense
knocking thoughts that you maintain
however that such shell companies
unnecessary do you have one yourself
harden Z denzel's Dinah 9 Midori horizon
no unfortunately not I'm not rich enough
and even if I were I wouldn't need to
hide my wealth but there are situations
in which people wish to conceal where
they keep their money yeah an example a
man has a child out of wedlock Lexus and
wants to provide for it without making
it known that he's the father merci
dismissal for you and gun whatever the
reason it's useful to have legal avenues
that allow payments to be made to a
child while the benefactor remains
anonymous Liam confessed to come through
doesn't notice there was 20 hits
whenever can do it one Zulu our merchant
fleets employ flags of convenience to
otherwise German known trading vessels
and container ships wouldn't travel they
need to fly the flag of the relevant
country flags of convenience require
legal frameworks so such firms have a
legal foundation tax avoidance within a
legal framework is not a crime education
to film and up kazinda on the story I've
have my room with your social
arrangement only makes sense if you
command a high income though otherwise
it just gets too expensive the design
for tutorial and if or when Steffie
firms might have a legal basis and yen
to luan ha but the revelations have
shown that regulations are often
advanced don't you think that there
should be more
transparency with regard to shell
companies in the future event the hon
top designers centimeter photographer he
would even if I were to call for that
and wouldn't help because we can't make
Panama bide by German law nobody can
expect the rest of the world to adopt
German laws or tax regulations tax
avoidance structures exist in Europe to
the Dutch don't have a withholding tax
on royalties so it's become a shelter
for earnings from intellectual property
tax rates on legal entities in Ireland a
lower fifteen percent tax on capital
vinegar Australian of dosage a Bedouin
from simple send copy Australia in
Germany its twenty five to thirty
percent but doesn't even fit the fact
that companies tried to relocate to the
place where they pay the least tax is
the price of freedom Germany alone can't
change that can you understand that
people in Germany at angry when they see
firms shoring up their money in tax
havens well they pay their taxes are
done in silence yes but these companies
are paying taxes just lower rates as in
Ireland for example I'm smirking because
I'm thinking of the village of nor the
friedrich school in my state of
schleswig-holstein it was made up of 13
farms and I don't know five hundred cows
but until 2003 it was home to 500 big
name companies Lufthansa aliens a on and
others which had subsidiaries located
there why because the community
abolished trade tanks taxation within
Germany is competitive there are more
subsidies for companies in the East than
in the West cities or states lure
companies with the promise of lower tax
burdens a German joint stock company
based in Germany can be involved in
criminal activities it doesn't need to
have a company in Panama for that I
think people have overreacted someone
it's probably true that their spots and
terrorists use offshore holding
structures but it's about the criminals
abusing them not the structures
themselves are their teeth at the
dentist you know be the constituents in
his power see I what nothing you work as
a lawyer specializing in tax law
you have reportedly also represented tax
evaders does that make you uncomfortable
mangan you really there's a fog away we
go I get asked this time and again it's
not up to me to decide I'm not the judge
I don't have to cast moral judgment I
just need to do my job one doesn't ask a
doctor treating a terrorist whether they
feel comfortable I just have to ensure
the process is in accordance with the
rule of law ferron H darkish Fulton yet
what do you like most about your job yet
some is already clean to use the clients
mostly I don't take on cases of
drug-related crime I'd also have an
issue with sexual assault cases I don't
take on political cases as I'm involved
in politics myself so we could be held
against me I'm chiefly an economist I
work with numbers and a lot of my work
is about evaluating festival eggwin I
enjoy looking at two different legal
areas and then coming to hopefully for
the client one sensible solution that
designer dancer on eachother Fatima done
to new fitting a year na sukham isn't
about bully but you are also a
politician the deputy chairman of the
fdp the apartheid your party has often
been criticized for cozying up to
business for yourself is this criticism
justified here politique to the time I'm
buddy the critic berated we r minus 90
then Zeki not when you look at our
members we have far fewer business
people than the Christian Democrats for
example we had less contact to
corporations and banks than to small and
medium-sized and family businesses I
don't think it's a bad thing to use
economic competence to safeguard the
country's prosperity some politicians
would be wise to think about how the
money they spend is generated unless it
prints money the state can't ensure
everyone has a job so in that respect I
don't think being close to businesses a
bad thing I don't hold anything against
a Green Party member with close ties to
environmental inside that chose for this
certainly clashes are to be expected how
facile in the democratic process is
about making the best out of these
different outlooks
after 45 years of party membership I
wish there were more people in
Parliament who came from professions
they knew a lot about I think Parliament
is full of people making decisions about
issues without any understanding of the
consequences Solomon mentioned
organisers Indian Tschida 174 Lindsay
kenichi business but his heart is young
about evidently voters felt differently
in the last federal elections in 2013
the ftp were booted out of parliament
for the first time ever what did you
personally learn from that it's me some
earnest money cookie for one that
criticism of the party leadership
between 2009 in 2013 was justified we
didn't lose because we were perceived as
too close to business but rather because
the people who elected us in 2009 had
lost confidence in the ability of party
leaders to make good on their campaign
promises as we went into the 2009
elections with a pledge went to juice a
lower simpler and fairer tax system
years that didn't succeed party leaders
appeared content to get their
ministerial portfolios before the
election we'd promised to unite the
ministry of foreign affairs with that of
Economic Cooperation and Development
instead both remained and were filled
with fdp candidates that gave rise to
the impression that we didn't stick to
our word and our popularity began to
slide right after the election if I in
value absolutely we had been at five
percent or below sin to 2010 hence the
result of the last election so mistakes
were made but they gave rise to a debate
as to whether the fdp was needed in
Germany at all do germans need the ftp
Yas manage each one EP a hot dog in my
view yes after all I am German and I
believe we need the attain the fact that
all opinion polls now put us at seven
percent is of positive signs I it shows
we're on the way up what do you guys
we've been back no matter where I am I
see a big demand for the free democrats
to offer solutions to our present
problems the ill-will is gone people are
flocking back
these an audience they are looking for a
party that can deal with questions
related to a social market economy
education tolerance openness and civil
rights I am very confident that we will
achieve a respectable result in the 2017
federal elections but acting like you is
action alone will it be all or nothing
for the ftp in the 2017 federal
elections in every election is all or
nothing much is in flux and after good
results in the state elections it's
important the fdp does well in the
federal ones for germany too because if
we have another four or five years
without any substantial opposition party
in parliament that poses important
questions how will we safeguard our
prosperity how will we develop ideas for
a new Europe so the EU doesn't fall
apart we're facing a possible brexit
this junit looking equites therefore for
implicit and union yaris the people will
decide will make them an offer and they
can accept or decline but I'm sure we'll
keep attracting people young ones too
who wants something out of life who want
to have a good outlook and not worry
about domestic security issues family
policy or their old age more and more
people are attracted to the fdp and our
popularity will grow in the opinion
polls and then in the election results
found an invalid abysm have to be at the
ftp has just repositioned itself ahead
of upcoming federal elections it also
has a new image and new leaders how are
you coping with that guitar I'm coping
with the fact that I'm deputy leader
very well I've also come to grips with
receiving almost ninety five percent of
the votes that would have been
unthinkable four or five years ago and
with the party's repositioning chimezie
wood-clad NVR there's a very good
working atmosphere not just in the
executive committee or between the
chairman myself and the others the
federal executive committee's working in
environment is open and constructive and
when someone takes an opposing view
they're not automatically accused of
acting with evil intentions that's also
part of our success we're back on track
people see we live up to our claim that
everyone has a right to voice their
previously when the party leader said
something it was basically set in stone
as may still be the case in other
parties but a democracy that's built on
the right two opposing views can't just
pay lip service to freedom of expression
it must practice it to like the ftp does
and because people see it's living up to
its own noble ideals the fdp has
recovered at a speed I wouldn't have
thought possible two years ago at the
end of the DW interview we ask our
guests to complete three sentences for
us once the proposed Indian for me
Straight Talk is the most important
thing in the world is only then do you
know what someone wants and can react a
life without politics is something I can
imagine not yet but in the foreseeable
future politics isn't everything an
honest person isn't stupid on the
contrary he or she lays the foundations
for coexistence mr. kabuki many thanks